une banderole pour un vaccin à l'origine
de ce message adressé au maire de
l'arrondissement geoffroy boulard et à
la députée brigitte thomas williams d
hassan un résident de la copropriété qui
tient le signal d'alarmé pour cet ex
légionnaire et industriels il est temps
d'agir
que voulait simplement dire que ça
commence à bien faire
comme tous les français je regarde notre
union et et j'écoute les provinces et
comme elles sont pas tenues ça m'ennuie
si la copropriété des hespérides est
uniquement habité par des personnes du
troisième âge
elle souffre de ne pas faire partie des
critères des ehpad autres maisons de
retraite ou organismes qui relèvent de
la sécurité sociale résultat la plupart
de ces 85 résidents pourtant à risques
ne sont pas prioritaires pour la
vaccination
fatalement l'anxiété s'installe j'ai un
cancer je suis très fragile sur le plan
cardiaque
je veux pas tirer la couverture en eau
maman va bien c'est que si j'attrape la
cohue du hummer si le conseil syndical
de la copropriété a fait retirer la
banderole quelques heures après son
déploiement
il soutient dans une certaine mesure le
coup d'éclat de cet habitant et espère
une réponse de la municipalité pour le
compte des copropriétaires nous sommes
rapprochés des instances ministérielles
nous sommes rapprochés des mairies ou
des ars locales afin d'essayer d'obtenir
une notion de priorités afin que les
résidents puissent bénéficier de
campagnes de vaccination dans ces
établissements
la difficulté c'est comme on est un peu
hors cadre on a du mal à se faire
entendre premier point et sans polémique
aucune
les maires sont confrontés au fait de
l'absence de doses de vaccins suffisante
et il est difficile donc d'obtenir ces
campagnes de vaccination au sein des
établissements en france le manque de
vaccination dans ces résidences pour les
aînés concerne environ 4000 personnes
qu'ils soient salariés de ces
établissements ou copropriétaires pour
le moment très peu de cas de
contamination et de personnes gravement
malades sont à déplorer au sein de ces
résidences et parmi la quarantaine
d'infrastructures similaires que compte
le pays
certaines ont déjà obtenu gain de cause
et sont désormais prioritaires dans la
campagne de vaccination reste à savoir
si l'action menée aux hespérides va
permettre à leurs résidents de
bénéficier du même traitement de faveur